deuxième sortie de la journée pour
nicolas victime d'un accident de moto à
35 ans ce polytraumatisé découvre le
wakeboard l'an dernier une révélation
pour l'ancien motard qui en est
aujourd'hui à sa 20e heure de pratique
sur l'eau comme sur la route il retrouve
les sensations de vitesse oublié on se
croirait un petit peu sur les pistes ne
neigeait service ça tirait un petit peu
il faut un maximum de gainage
et après voir mes cervicales tout ça on
en prend un coup au début ça ça tire un
peu il ya des courbatures qui se forment
et si on pratique régulièrement on se
fait la cour des
invalides ou valide petits ou grands
néophytes ou professionnels sur ce plan
d'eau aux airs de fin du monde
la pratique de la glisse s'ouvre à tous
on a eu champion de france qui est
passée aujourd'hui mais à la fois on a
eu des débutants on a eu aussi une
personne qui avait des difficultés à ce
qui est qu'ici on a pu la faire
progresser on a tous les niveaux en fait
il n'ya pas de distinction chez nous
vous allez trouver à autour de la table
à la fois champion de france et le
débutant qui vont se parler on va
discuter matériel glisse qui aidé par la
fédération le club rend le stage gratuit
et accessible à tous afin de
démocratiser l'univers du ski nautique
sur bateau au grand bonheur de chacun
[Musique]